I have to tell you like I was in the
trailer during lunch one day and it was
the whole cast like the new cast not the
new cast the cast of see it's weird the
cast of Bel-Air kind of greeting me and
with this like enthusiastic drum roll on
and that's so much like the way we all
are when we're together the you know
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
um and I told you know I told the the
Casper was that I talked to I was like
yo they call you you should do it it's
crazy yeah forever let anyone try to
change you the real Will Smith is a
executive producer on this did you have
a chance to talk to him about you going
back and doing this and I didn't get a
chance to talk to him but when I was on
set and they were banging on my trail
like I told you we had great
conversations we took lots of pictures
and I texted him
um some of those pictures and I said I'm
having the time of my life he said it
made him very happy yeah
Ashley can I talk to you it's what was
it like when you talked to a care come
on I care she's playing Ashley she's
amazing you gotta eat so we Face Time to
kind of while she was behind the scenes
and I met her mom on that call and
she's just so beautiful and and and so
genuine
um such like a beautiful girl and I just
told her I was like you know we're in a
very small sorority it's just me and you
we're the only two Ashley banks that
have ever been and do your thing you
know let your light shine and I think
she has
very much so you know reboots happen
this one happened in such a different
way it's a complete reimagining it's its
own show so I didn't know but Akira
Akbar is the reason why it's awesome
it's just such a full circle moment and
what my character was saying to her it
felt very much like I was like looking
at myself in a way you always connect to
your character like that anyway and the
other actors in that way it's always
personal on some level but this was just
another
another thing how does the old G the OG
group feel about the new group like how
and what kind of interaction goes on and
yeah and what do you all say when you're
talking about the new show
everybody has their own feelings yes for
the most part I think it's I think it's
good I think we all feel very much like
they've taken the the initial the
concept of the show and made it their
own and run with it you know that it is
its own show and I think now that it's
in its second season I mean the proof of
concept is there now they've got Wings
They're Gonna Fly With It do you think
somebody else will do it or others will
do it because it is such an amazing
experience like for me watching it's
like you want to scream at the TV you're
like
and then you have to watch it again you
know first of all artistically
the best
incredible obviously incredible actors
Incredible Crew incredible directors
the writing's wonderful who do you want
to see next who do you want to come back
and play a different character
who do you want to who would you want to
come back
Karen would have a blast I think Alfonso
would have a blast I think Joseph Marcel
would be decided so Daphne Reed did a
cameo in the very first season I think
with Renee Watson Johnson who was who
was Will's mother in the original sitcom
um I don't know maybe a little by little
the peppers and I don't know I was
totally shocked that I got that off I
was like really how did they come and
Matthew just called you and you said hey
it came the way my you know other work
comes and and it's funny it's like I
know it I really felt like oh
what's this role I love the show it's a
great show what's the role and I guess I
kind of treated it like that I didn't I
didn't realize how
um
that even all this would be a part of it
I was like oh
dates work out that'll be fun
I can do this to you fight for your
principles
do all this you know you get to play
um and then on top of that to have that
The Meta thing happening I don't even
know what to call it somebody called it
like a legacy I don't know if that's
what it is I can't figure out what it is
but to have that on top of it the sort
of emotional full circleness of it is
just who gets to do that really like
what do you get to do that in your life
or in your career like it's weird it's
cool
um I saw the first episode of the second
season are there any Easter eggs in
there will there be things that people
that will make people say oh wow I know
that line or this thing did you all hide
anything in there intentionally I don't
know if they did and you know I'm a
recurring so I'm in a few you know a few
episodes of the show
um but I even noticed as a viewer in the
first season that there were Easter eggs
relationship Easter eggs things that
they like teased out of the
relationships and the characters that I
that like I was there when we were
rehearsing as a kid and those things
kind of developed and bubbled up not
even formalized is in the words but in
the way you know Jeffrey and and Uncle
Phil having this relationship before
the family you know just as men at some
other point in their life like they
teased all that stuff out and all that
there's a through line with that so I'm
sure there's much more this season and
how different was it being on the set
and not needing to hit the jokes like
you know Fresh Prince of Bel-Air is
about the jokes oh yeah it's a sitcom
it's it's timing it's Rhythm what is
this Daddy it's a diamond
no it isn't
can you tell me about transforming into
a drag queen how was that oh chakra
seven yes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that was
um just the experience of a lifetime I
was so excited about the invitation to
do celebrity drag race I I'm a huge fan
of the show yeah since it started years
ago and it was on Logo Channel and at
first I thought oh you know I I kind of
am in drag when I have to work and
whatever I have to do my hair no ma'am
no I'm not it's not the same it's not
the same it's not the same
um I just uh
it just felt like a for me like kind of
like a Reawakening artistically and
which is why I always loved the show
there's such
complete artists
[Music]
[Applause]
but what was the thing that you loved
the most about the transformation like
where there was one thing that you were
like oh my God I love this was it the
hair the clothes I love the relationship
with my drag mother Brooklyn Heights
she's incredible and she truly mentored
me and I love my big butt let me tell
you something I had padding on because
they asked me they're like do you want
patio I was like I don't know I don't
need that they're like well there is a
proportion that you know we sometimes go
for TR and I said let me try it
you were like I was like
the padding and then the corset I was
like oh you can't talk to me anymore
wow
and then the big hair to match that I
was a total hourglass with the hair and
the booty and the corset
it's like no one can talk to me I could
do anything it was magic right it was it
was magical it was magical
[Music]